god's timing certainly isn't my timing
as we learn in the book of isaiah his
thoughts are not our thoughts and his
ways are not our ways
god calls us to trust him even when we
cannot understand current circumstances
and to be patient even when we want to
accelerate work in his name
these are two of the recurring lessons
god has taught me throughout my life
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here
but i've completed this first
task
100 days
on a rooftop living in a tent
bringing to you every single day my
thoughts
viewpoints and opinions
right here on rooftop revelation
trying to raise the funds to build a
community center on a much needed block
that the gangs called o block
we decided we're going to keep that o
but we are changing it to opportunity
block
it's been an amazing journey
fox has been a tremendous blessing
giving me this opportunity
to bring to you every day
rooftop revelations and i am forever
grateful
for the past 100 days
and 99 bitter cold nights
i've been camped out on top of these
eight shipping containers on the south
side of chicago
at a location where our church hopes to
build a new community center
my plan was to spend 100 nights upon the
rooftop to raise funds for the center
while also raising awareness
of the plague of violence in chicago
100 days upon the roof in chicago's
winner i figured would be more than
enough to raise the funds
to build a community center
but my timing as is often the case
was not god's timing
while fundraising is going well and we
have been blessed by the generosity of
so many donors
we've not yet met our goal
for the past few weeks i have sensed
that god was telling me to stay up on
the roof until the fundraising for this
project was complete
i know it was god's voice telling me to
remain on the roof because it certainly
wasn't my heart's desire
temperatures have gotten down to minus
20 degrees with the windshield factor
and i have been
eagerly looking at my calendar counting
the days until i would come down from
this rooftop
during my time up here i've invited ceos
of major corporations religious leaders
college presidents and politicians to
spend the night camping out with me
those who have camped out with me have
seen firsthand why our community is in
need of more resources
and better programs for our youth
the woodlawn neighborhood on the south
side of chicago
is known for gun violence in fact
during my time up on this roof i've
heard countless gunshots fired with
near-constant sounds of police sirens
waiting in the background
this is a community where nearly 50
percent of the households make less than
25
000 a year poverty is rampant and
fatherlessness is rampant our feelings
are hopelessness
hopelessness and fear are the primary
emotions that compel young men in
chicago to join violent gangs in the
first place
but feelings of rootedness in a
relationship with jesus a strong sense
of self-worth and ties to the community
are the three best ways to prevent
growth of gangs and to help young men
transition from being violent gang
members to productive members of our
society
this pervasive hopelessness
on the south side of chicago is
precisely why we feel so called to
create this center
so god can transform even the most
hopeless individuals and in my 22 years
of serving as a pastor in this community
i've seen the life-changing
transformation that only god
can orchestrate
i worked with former gang members to
help them receive training to start a
new career
and even more importantly a new life
with positions in construction lawn
service industry and restaurant industry
[Music]
often these men are desperate to be
given a second chance
through our church new beginnings church
and project hood
we've given them that opportunity to get
a fresh start in life
this vision for our future community
center is simple
with an 85 000
square foot center we will be able to
expand the programs and services to more
individuals our plan
is that this community center will
become the center of our community
providing hope and a future to a
forgotten neighborhood we will offer
tools to children and to young adults to
reach their god-given potential where
their we'll have classes and job
trainings and
all of these financial literacy things
to improve them we have gym facilities
music facilities art facilities these
spaces will be used to hold community
meetings and we'll distribute necessary
care and food and diapers to the
community
these are not handouts the way the
government carelessly scatters resources
these items are all given as recognition
that we can change people that we can
help them to change their life that we
can change the cycles of poverty and
helplessness
the needs of our community are vast
they're large in part because of the
government has for decades
caused us to have a sense of dependency
and the government has totally failed us
with all of these programs
government are all level state
local federal
it has
failed our community entirely
and our intention is to step in where
government has systematically
failed
to meet our individual needs the initial
plan
that we started was to break ground on
the center in the spring and lord
willing we will eventually reach that
goal with your help
god's timing certainly isn't my timing
as we learn in the book of isaiah his
thoughts are not our thoughts and his
ways are not our ways
god calls us to trust him even when we
cannot understand current circumstances
and to be patient even when we want to
accelerate work in his name
these are two of the recurring lessons
god has taught me throughout my life
so for now
i will remain camped out on this roof
in the words of nehemiah
as he worked to rebuild the wall of
jerusalem
i can't come down
not until the work is finished
and not until the job is complete not
until the purpose is fulfilled
and god
has completed
what he has started
i want to thank all of you
over this last 100 days
for being so faithful
for being so
generous
i'm so appreciative for the rest of my
life to fox
for giving me this platform
i want to say thank you to eli steele
who has produced such a magnificent show
every single day
thank you to terrell for staying out in
the cold
on some cold bitter nights
so that we can communicate a truth that
needs to be told
from a perspective that is seldom heard
from voices that you seldom hear from
from the south side of chicago
and i'm reminded when they said
when jesus was born can good can any
good thing
come out of nazareth
well
sometimes i feel the same way about the
south side of chicago
people are asking
can any good thing
come from the south side of chicago
and my answer is
positivity
absolutely
yes
thank you
for tuning in
to rooftop revelations
and if it's god's will
hopefully i'll see you again tomorrow
because guess what
i'm not going anywhere
until the job is done
god bless you
god bless america
and until tomorrow
another rooftop revelation
peace
you